des propriétaires de cabanes à sucre et
de salle de réception se sont réunis
aujourd'hui à montréal pour lancer un
appel au secours au gouvernement du
québec
ces entrepreneurs disent être au bout du
rouleau et soulignent que les
conséquences de la crise sont
particulièrement importants dans leur
secteur d'activité
on va en parler avec jean-paul perdre il
est co propriétaire de l'érablière du
cap à lévis merci d'être là monsieur
vous avez donc une entreprise de
production de sirop d'érable vous avez
aussi une salle de réception qui est
ouverte à l'année habituellement comment
ça se passe avec la pandémie depuis le
15 mars
puis 15 mars c'est zéro ne se passe plus
rien papa de clients pas d'activité
parce que là évidemment il ya eu des
confinement tout de même lire les
rassemblements 250 personnes sont sont
autorisés il ya pas moyen d'avoir
ne serait-ce que le moindre client bien
regarder nous les cabanes à sucre
commercial les salles de réception et
aussi charles l'asa sanctionne à
réservation
donc notre cahier était complet pas
complet mais il était très avancée au
mois de mars
on avait des activités toutes les
semaines et particulièrement à mars à
avril c'est la grande période mais tous
les autres mois on avait des activités
dès que la pandémie a été déclaré que le
gouvernement a demandé à ce que première
journée on diminue à 250 ha deuxième
journée c'était 50 % de la capacité et
la 3e journée c'était finale eh bien
tous les gens ont quand ce lien c'est
que vous comprendrez que des
réservations ça ne se prend pas à la
dernière minute c'est des mois et des
mois al avance donc à partir du 15 2
mars
toutes les réservations qu'on avait
aujourd'hui je peux vous dire jusqu'au
10 octobre c'est tout quand c'est les
mêmes prochaine réservation le cil 10
octobre
c'est un mariage on sait même pas si on
pourra le tenir parce que au nombre de
personnes qui va y avoir la mariée tient
absolument mais si les mesures se
desserre probablement comme on pourra le
faire mais si ça se resserre
probablement que pau est ce qu'on
comprend donc c'est qu'il ya pas de
revenus depuis plusieurs mois que ce
sera long avant d'en générer vous avez
quel genre de ressources financières il
ya des programmes tout de même qui
existe en ce moment vous avez quoi là
pour faire face à cette situation priori
le gouvernement du québec canada ont
permis une emprunts auprès des banques
de 40000 dollars qui est mis à notre
disposition pour subvenir aux besoins ce
quarante mille dollars est prêté sans
intérêt pour deux ans ou à peu près
jusqu'à la fin 2022
et si on rembourse
ce quarante mille dollars à la hauteur
de 30 mille dollars mais le dernier
disait données en subventions à la
presse cette période là sinon au début
on parlait le pc mais l'appétit n'était
pas le bon moyen et on nous ne sommes
pas des dates en est puisque depuis ce
temps là c'est la subvention salariale
de 75%
moi mon épouse et mes filles on est là
dessus depuis ce temps là ça nous permet
de vivre notre vie de au quotidien nous
personnellement mais l'entreprise sait
rien il ya eu le 40000 et c'est tout
mais vous comprendrez que les factures
sont leurs mains que ça coûte joliment
cher ça l'air de rien mais c'est pas
notre trente mille dollars par mois que
ça coûte garder sa ferme et alors vous
imaginez on voit clairement hier du cap
et nous on est chanceux on avait
provisionné des sommes pour faire des
grands travaux
cette année c'était prévu en 2020 et en
opposition sur la glace c'est ça pour
subvenir aux besoins de l'entreprise
ouais ça fait ça fait cinq mois le site
arrêté qu'est-ce que vous demander au
gouvernement de serbie
qu'est ce qu'on m'a premièrement que la
subvention salariale doit continuer tant
et aussi longtemps qu'on pourra pas
commencer à faire des réceptions qui en
valent la peine
on veut qu'ils aient une subvention
directe aux entreprises là tous les
gouvernements nous dit on qu'on n'y ont
pas eu d aller faire des emprunts nous
capables de faire un emprunt
quand il ya pas de revenus - je connais
personne sur la terre est capable de
faire ça donc c'est impensable donc vous
apprendre subventions directes dans les
cabanes à sucre commercial dans les
salles de réception même les entreprises
touristiques
nous on vit le restant de l'année avec
du touriste mais mon prochain point
c'est d'ouvrir les frontières n'y a pas
de tour et vous attendons y a pas de
touristes en ce moment il ya aucun
touriste donc moi le reste de l'année je
recevais beaucoup de touristes
présentement je peux pas et tous les
hôtels et restaurants qui faisait du
touristiques sont dans la même banque -
peuvent pas dans ça il y en a pas et
quand est ce que ça va commencer
on repose toujours la dent
c'était le 21 juillet 21 où j'ai
l'impression que ça va être le 31
décembre
est ce que vous êtes inquiets pour la
pérennité de l'entreprise et ce que vous
songez à faire faillite ou c'est vous
allez tenir jusqu'au bout
le bruit ou si je si vous vous êtes que
debout il 31 décembre je vais être
encore là si vous n'êtes que le goût il
31 juillet 2021 pour être capable de me
rendre jusque là puis c'est ce concept
on nous parle d'une deuxième pandémie
qui vont être payés que la première donc
imaginer même on fait des pubs on essaye
d'attirer les gens chez nous les gens
tellement pas de se réunir et dole
provenir on avait des mariages de ces
deux légendes dit non on ferait pas de
mariage cette année on voit repoussée à
l'année prochaine ou en vacances et les
lesjak se réunissaient pour faire des
parts et ici nous ont tout cassé les
ondes ou non peut pas se réunir tout à
coup qu'on se contaminent mais c'est
rentrer dans la tête des gens et puis on
peut pas espérer à court terme de
recevoir des gens mais jean neveu
provenir veulent pas se réunit à cette
civilisation du petit groupe vraiment
délicate mais vous vous êtes actif
monsieur tardy vous faites partie d'un
comité avec plusieurs autres
propriétaires de cabanes à sucre pour
essayer de sauver dynamiser l'industrie
ce qu'est ce que vous avez un appui
suffisant de l'association des
acériculteurs c'est la première fois que
j'étais connaissez mon assureur qui a
refusé d'être dédommagés même si l on je
me croyais assuré la 2e porte mais j'ai
été voir les producteurs acéricoles
producteurs et productrices acéricole
une cabane à sucre commercial ça fait
pas partie de l'upm ayant accepté de
nous défendre et on a fait plusieurs
réunions ces réunions l'on donnait une
demande qui a été transmise au ministre
de l'agriculture et le ministre
l'agriculture sa réponse a été nous est
pas pire que les restaurants donc fait
voter oui on y paient que des
restaurants parce que ni tous ceux qui
font du tourisme sont touchés depuis
cinq mois puis n'a vraiment on va
toucher encore pour les sept à huit
prochains mois peut-être 12 prochains
mois ou touristiques
un rebond difficile pour bien des gens
en particulier pour votre industrie on
doit s'arrêter là-dessus jour merci
beaucoup d'avoir été là monsieur tard ça
m'a fait plaisir à voir